Iq is a very good predictor of health.
It's a predictor of longevity.
It's a predictor of resistance to
posttraumatic stress disorder.
It's a predictor of obviously
occupational status.
It's a predictor of educational success.
That's a predictor of income.
It's very powerful predictive,
and here's another way of
conceptualizing its effect,
so imagine that you could choose how you
were going to be when you were born,
and this is in North America because
it's going to vary by society at least
to some degree.
You get to be born into a family that's
at the 95th percentile for wealth or you
get to be born at the 95th percentile
for intelligence who's better off at the
age of 40,
and the answer is the person who picks
being born with an Iq in the 95th
percentile at birth,
it's more powerful predictor of longterm
life outcome.
Then familiar wealth so
and it shows up everywhere.
Like one of the things we did recently
was looking at disgust sensitivity.
We're going to talk a little bit about
that when we talk about
conscientiousness because orderly people
seem to be more sensitive to discuss the
disorderly people.
That seems to be why they're orderly,
but the higher you are in Icu,
the less disgust sensitive you are.
Now we don't know exactly why that is.
Maybe it's because you know,
maybe you could make the inference that
Iq is,
is interrelated in some way to the
physiological integrity of the cortex.
You know,
rather than the limbic system which you
know is the source of say emotions and
motivations and the more powerful it is,
the more inhibitory capacity it has over
the more fundamental motivations and
emotions you could make.
That case.
Problem is,
is that intelligent people don't
necessarily seem to be any less
impulsive.
So and you can have a pretty vicious
personality disorder that's
characterized by extremely disorganized
behavior and a complete inability to put
longterm plans into operation and still
have a high Iq.
So what are the things we really can't
figure out?
It's just a hell of a thing to try to
figure out is like the relationship
between Iq and industriousness is zero
and that just makes no sense to me
because most of the brain models are
predicated on the idea that your ability
to engage in longterm planning is a
factor that's associated with
intelligence.
But then industrious people seem to not
only engage in longterm planning,
they seem to do it right.
So then if they're more industrious,
they put their plans into operation,
then the plan is actually work,
but it's not correlated with our queue.
So then I can't figure out,
well obviously the industrious person in
some way is able to regulate their own
behavior.
They're not procrastinating,
for example.
And you'd think that that the ability to
not procrastinate would be a cognitive
feature,
but it doesn't seem to be.
And we have no idea what makes people
industrious and we can't figure it out.
So it's this incredibly potent
predictors just about as powerful as ICU
and we have no idea what it is.
So.
So if you,
you know,
if you think,
if you have a smart idea about that and
you want to pursue it,
like feel free because there's a big
mystery there that no one's been able to
crack and we'd been at it for a long
time and have had almost no success.
You know,
we had people do things like give them
sentences of ends,
ams and use sort of randomly distributed
and then we'd have them count the use,
you know,
like a whole page of sentences.
They're not sentences.
So just strings of letter count the use
how useless,
you know,
you'd think that someone industrious
would do that better.
It's like they don't.
That's an Iq test.
The people who can count the use faster
have hierarchy cues.
Almost everything that you would do that
would wear it has to do with
manipulation of abstractions of any
sort.
Even something that basic seems to be
fundamentally associated with Iq.
People with higher iqs have slightly
bigger heads.
If you control for body size,
they have slightly bigger brains.
the axons on their neurons are a bit
thicker.
So the electrical messages seem to
travel a little bit more efficiency
efficiently.
They are slightly faster in simple
reflex test.
So it goes right down to the level of.
Because they're simple reflex light goes
on question bottom.
There's not many neurons mediating that
response,
you know,
chains of neurons.
There's only a few neurons communicating
so that you can do that.
But even at that relatively simple
processing level,
Iq is associated with speed.
So there's a physiological component,
you're less likely to develop
Alzheimer's disease if you have a high
Iq.
And maybe that's because your brain is
just more robust,
you know,
so you could sustain damage,
say up to 50 percent of your brain and
you wouldn't even show it if you're,
if you have a sufficiently high Iq.
Whereas if you're,
you know,
if you're on the bottom end of the ICU
distribution,
you're much more,
you seem to be much more susceptible to,
to physiological damage.
Nutrition is a big predictor of Iq
variation.
So,
and a lot of that's been hammered out of
modern societies,
you know,
so 150 years ago,
people's Iq was pretty tightly
associated with their nutritional
status.
But now,
you know,
there are very few people in North
America who don't have enough to eat
even though there's some variation in
quality of diet.
And that's flat note a lot of the,
uh,
cultural variability in an intelligence.